transcurre la jornada número 2 de la cop
15 la Cumbre de las Naciones Unidas para
la diversidad biológica que se celebra
desde este 7 de diciembre en el Palacio
del Congreso de Montreal en esta
oportunidad En esta segunda jornada la
agenda es muchísimo más movida no
solamente por el trabajo que ya viene
realizando los negociadores sino que
también hay una serie de eventos
paralelos organizados por distintos
actores sociales como mujeres pueblos
indígenas también todo lo que tiene que
ver con los jóvenes y su participación
en este proceso de protección ambiental
y también temas que tienen que ver con
aspectos financieros Pero hay una buena
noticia en relación a las negociaciones
Y es que se ha logrado llegar a un
acuerdo en tres de las metas que forman
parte de las 22 de ese borrador inicial
del marco global para la biodiversidad
que se espera probar de aquí hasta el
final de la Cumbre el 19 de diciembre
esto es una buena noticia pero hay un
gran reto Y es que el texto todavía
tiene más de 1000 esos corchetes tienen
que ver con todas esas áreas en las
cuales todavía no hay un consenso Así
que se han creado una docena de grupos
de contacto que son grupos pequeños
grupos que tienen conversaciones
privadas que no están abiertas al
público para poder ayudar a que esta
discusión avance y se pueda luego llevar
el trabajo a los grupos más grandes de
trabajo y posteriormente se pueda llevar
a la plenaria donde finalmente se pueden
lograr aprobar estos distintos aspectos
que forman parte de este documento que
se espera probar de aquí al final de la
cop 15